be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are getting into tales of the
dark multiverse and to be honest I'm
kind of surprised it took them this long
to make this right like this that this
is kind of interesting here's the cool
thing about this tales from the dark
multiverse really seems more like to the
what-if stories like more akin to the
what-if stories from all around I mean
technically it's named after tales the
Lantern Corps by Geoff Johns during his
Green Lantern run but the difference
between those is it tales of the Green
Lantern Corps basically dealt with like
the backstory the history behind a lot
of the Lantern Corps is that we were
being introduced to Elsa was really more
of like filler stuff albeit super
important but still filler stuff and on
the less this feels like a what-if story
and it feels like it's just called tales
of the dark multiverse her tales from
the dark multi worst I don't have a
problem with it right it's it's a cool
concept I dig it and then they've
confirmed a bunch of others like
identity crisis Infinite Crisis like
it's night Teen Titans I haven't looked
at the solicitation suppose you guys
don't know comics are like you're
basically given like when they're gonna
cut out three months in advance that way
like comic book stores can prepare for
them bottle do they have dates for those
but regardless of the circumstance this
opens up almost identical to a what-if
story like a would have story from
Marvel features The Watcher and it's
like I am The Watcher and some stuff
popping off and let me show you and
that's basically how it goes right this
goes the exact same way the difference
with this is that unlike the what-if
stories where each universe is his own
cohesive story and you can read each one
independent of the other this is the
same to a degree but it all shares the
common theme that all these stories take
place in the dark multiverse of DC
Comics right so it's actually pretty
cool but this is given to us by what's
basically DC's version of The Watcher
tempest Fujinon now tempest fighter not
he actually originally appeared in the
sideways stories by Kenneth Rocca for
way back brilliant as part of the New
Age of Heroes right so he's been around
for a little bit but but DC's never
really done anything with it but the
fact remains though real meat potatoes
of this comes by way of the main
nightfall story itself now the idea of
this follows the follows the the same
form and function in so far as Bane
showed up in Gotham Bane broke Batman's
back and Batman basically appointed
jean-paul Valley to become the new
Batman and then ultimately Bruce Wayne
in the main DC Universe came back and
then became Batman again and this one
jean-paul Valley kills him right because
the idea behind valley when he was
Batman is he was pretty brutal like he
was pretty hardcore I was one of these
things worse like he's not Batman the
way he's supposed to be he's batman
based on like what john paul valley
thinks you should do in terms of
functioning within the confines of the
order of st. Dumas this kind of really
hardcore like cult religious group and
then bringing like a far more intense
and really sort of rough edge to the
Batman mythos so unlike the
main DC Universe war Batman succeeded in
defeating jean-paul Valley ultimately
Valley kills him like he basically ends
up killing Bruce Wayne or at least
that's kind of how it all kicks off
right and so following that basically
Gotham City's torn down and rebuilt
again right there's a pretty huge flame
that according to you know Azrael in the
order of st. Dumas cleanses away all the
sin and then in turn is built back up in
the in the image of what it is that the
jean-paul Valley believes the Gotham
City should be and so what this does is
it jumps forward by 30 years and this is
awesome
right because what you end up getting is
you get what used to be Wayne Manor but
is now the the Dumas home and he's
basically married to Madeleine now I did
some poking around here and those are
the guys who are a lot more
knowledgeable about about John Paul
Valley than I am could probably answer
this question but I'm not familiar with
the care to name Madeleine and I was
poking around and I couldn't find one
like I couldn't find a character named
Madeline who was intrinsically tied into
the original bat nightfall story arc and
I did find a couple verses of Madeline
that existed out there but they really
seemed more of like one-off villains or
old school villains or something like
that they didn't really seem to have any
involvement like any big involvement in
the Batman mythos it would give us a
reason to believe that she would go on
to marry Azrael when he became Batman I
haven't been able to find it but as I've
told you guys before I'm a lot less
knowledgeable about DC than I am about
Marvel right like I'm still relatively
new to DC I didn't really start reading
it till the new 52 right since 2011 so
nonetheless you know those guys who are
knowledgeable about that feel free to
feel free to drop some knowledge bombs
down in the in the comments but what's
also interesting to note here is that
John Paul Valley is actually using venom
now in the old nightfall stories are
really the the nightfall in post
nightfall landscape jean-paul Valley
could actually like overcome venom it's
addictive nature within like a day right
it's one of the big claims to fame with
this character in terms of his resolve
his enhanced abilities and and so on and
so forth in this one he's full-blown
gone into it right like he's full-blown
taking it on and it's a cool thing to
see because it sort of amplifies and
really shows us like how far down the
rabbit hole jean-paul Valley's fallen
but at the same time like he's also
going to Wayne Manor Wayne tower in
order to I guess essentially play out a
scenario that always plays out the same
way every year since it originally
happened and what is it going on here is
that Valley travels directly to Wayne
Tower and we end up finding out that
Bruce Wayne is alive Bruce Wayne's
hooked up to a kind of system of sorts
it basically keeps his brain alive and
the john-paul valley can can basically
talk to him and it's kind of nuts here
because what he ends up doing is
basically like trying to get Bruce Wayne
to believe that like he's the right kind
of Batman and ultimately Bruce Wayne's
kind like no you're not and this is a
really cool exchange between the two
because the way the jean-paul Valley
view's Bruce is that he was a high
a lot of ways he was right I mean we
taught her that before Batman was a
terrible superhero right like Batman was
a bad superhero because Gotham City was
worse off after Batman got there that it
was before he was there because now you
had all the things that Bruce Wayne
dealt with as a kid or at least that was
there before I became Batman and then
now you have super villains on top of it
too he believes that all super villains
can be redeemed and being cured despite
the fact that consistently showing that
they haven't aah means that like there's
no way they could and then three people
usually kind of kind of that argument by
saying well me if they killed off all
the different villains about i wouldnt
have anybody to fight against that's
true that's the role of a writer is to
create new villains to create new
characters and stuff it's one of these
things where like Batman's just
consistently a bad superhero because
it's just like Gotham City's no better
off than it was when he first got there
right and it's kind of a cool thing
because Valley's responses like I'm a
better Batman than you ever worked
because all these various villains that
are here have all been essentially taken
out by me I did what you could not do
like I've made Gotham better and in a
lot of ways he has and in some ways he
has and this goes into like the the the
moral debate that we have on here all
the time right like freedom versus
security if people really want a free
society then with that also comes the
fact that like crappy things are gonna
happen to you and so if what you want is
a completely secure Society
then you sacrifice freedom in response
to that so how do you get both and
they're just kind of have to be a
balance there but getting getting part
of one does like you don't get fifty
percent like I'm so you don't get a
hundred percent of freedom and a hundred
percent of security you get fifty
percent of each because there's only a
hundred percent to go around and so you
have to sacrifice one for the other in
some form or fashion
those scales have to sort of be
maintained and in some way and so it's
kind of cool because what Valley's
chosen here is basically like a
heavy-handed approach and saying like I
rule the city of Gotham I control the
city of Gotham it does what I wanted to
do and it functions in the way that I
wanted to do now there have been
attempts to overthrow jean-paul Valley
over the years and that's one of the
things that Bruce Wayne says it's like
if your rule was so absolute and if your
rule was so solid if you were such a
great leader like you believed you are
then why are people trying to overthrow
you and the reality is that revolutions
are launched by people who just want
things to change from where they are at
the moment their motivations go from
person to person maybe they believe that
what's going on right now is more
oppressive they believe maybe they
believe they can just do better right
like warlords over top with you know
toppling other warlords you know
whatever the case is but but regardless
the situation like revolutions happen
for any number of reasons it doesn't
necessarily mean jean-paul Valley's a
crappy ruler it just means maybe
somebody else thought they could do
better and so at the end of the day like
I would side with jean-paul Valley here
like I would say John Paul Valley was
right like at the end of the day he
became a better Batman than than Bruce
Wayne did because what the city needed
at this
was not going to cast off villains on
its own right if the citizenry of Gotham
were just going to sit idly by because
they just kind of sat back rested on
their laurels and let Batman take care
of everything for them that ultimately
they Gotham City they deserve in the
city they deserved was one controlled by
an absolute ruler because that's what
they were asking for and so it's a it's
a cool scenario it's kind of a cool
little thing and so ultimately what you
end up finding out here is that not
every single villains taken outright
like characters like the penguin well he
does run a business to a degree
there are dealings that are being done
with jean-paul Valley in terms of
working with penguin capturing various
people different things like that but
you end up finding out that what penguin
had been doing was smuggling various
arms and armament into the city of
Gotham and then ultimately his actions
are discovered and they're handed over
to John Paul Valley who basically says
take care of it and so ultimately the
penguin is is taken out right like he's
eliminated not only that is kind of like
this this statement that's given to
these guys given to the soldiers of John
Paul Valley when they basically say like
hey look you guys can't stop what's
coming here like what's coming is going
to turn everything that you know upside
down and this entire city is going to
fall apart because of it and in that
moment over the course of that night
five separate explosions take place all
across the city of Gotham you end up
having Azrael who basically pumps up his
venom serum and who jumps out into the
frame and then you're met by this kid
seemingly out of nowhere right let these
kid this kind of appears there and it's
ultimately just sort of you know like
okay let's launch our mission let's do
what we're supposed to do now this kid
is legit do this kid a song right this
kid's like it he's like a ninja right
he's like taking every single one of
these soldiers out he does it in like
quick precision and then ultimately gets
to Wayne Tower and gets to Bruce Wayne
and that's when we learned that this
kid's name is Luis and that he's the son
of Bane and it's the coolest thing ever
because it's like dude this is awesome
like when soldiers start funneling in
here this kids like hold on one second
he like amps up he just like juices up
becomes as big as Bane and crushes these
guys and this this is a character I hope
they bring back right I want to see him
return and the reason why is because
this kid because of the fact that that
Bane took so much of the venom juice the
venom serum it basically permeated his
cells right and so ultimately when when
this kid was born that was passed on to
him meaning he could become as strong
and as in as like powerful as Bane but
he doesn't require venom it's a natural
augmentation of his body and he and just
will it to happen what an awesome power
and I want to see him return like I want
to see him come back because this kid is
exceedingly capable and what you end up
learning here is this massive attack is
launched on two fronts right the idea is
to essentially create a massive
distraction I create these explosions
incite insurrection in the city
Gotham try to get the citizenry to do
something to get up off their backsides
like do something to take their city
back and then in turn while all that's
going on and while all the forces of
Azrael and ezreal and suffer totally
distracted by all these explosions this
kid's gonna sneak in and this kid is
basically going to free Bruce Wayne and
at the end of the day it doesn't really
seem to make any difference though
because Bruce Wayne is just kind of
there right I mean he's literally a head
and a spine like his limbs have been cut
off like one limb was cut off every year
at least one part of him was cut off
every year over the course of 30 years
by Azrael right like it was just a
really gruesome tactic and it was a
pretty cruel thing to do but that's
literally all this has been and so what
you end up doing is basically getting
you know kind of this discussion between
the two with Bruce Wayne and with the
son of Bane and this is awesome right
this is a really really cool discussion
because what you end up doing is is you
kind of look at this from the
perspective of okay this is the son of
Bane the man who broke the bat so my
first thought would be this kid wants to
like take out Batman and then take out
Azrael and then conquer Gotham City but
I said it doesn't work that way instead
the way this this functions is that this
kid by you know by whatever manner and
whatever means is siding with Bruce
Wayne insane like Gotham City as it
exists now is not Gotham City the way
it's supposed to be and the reality of
this is this is a stark change from what
we would normally expect right I mean
like even if you're going you're reading
city of Bane right now by Tom King which
is an amazing story the whole thing is
that like Bane wants to conquer Gotham
City which he's done well you
successfully managed to do you would
expect him to side against Batman and
that's not what happens it's like I'm on
your side here I'm here to bring Gotham
back to what it was before now again I
saw I still say as y'all made a better
Gotham City so it's like yeah like we're
gonna take off and back to a place where
like criminals ran it and people were
like living in fear and dying all the
time because the Joker was losing his
mind it's kind of an interesting thing
here because what you end up learning is
that the mother of this guy that the the
mother this kid the one that's really
kind of brought him out here and taught
him all these things is Lady Shiva now
in the main DC Universe Lady Shiva is a
mother of four Fionn but orphan doesn't
really seem to exist here she doesn't
seem to function in this this particular
universe instead it's the son of Bane as
it was interesting because basically
everything he's learned about being an
assassin assuming that Lady Shiva still
had her ties to the League of Assassins
like Ra's al Ghul and all those guys she
still knew all that community was still
part of the group for a while assuming
that she's still broke off and that she
eventually had took him on and he became
you know this produced assassin assuming
that's all the case then everything
still kind of plays out the same in
terms of her history that's kind of
interesting there but she's still super
capable and one of the best people to
teach anybody how to become a 4-digit
fighter not only that what you end up
learning is that what they've done
they basically brought this kind of
nanite technology that can essentially
give Bruce Wayne a body and that's
exactly what it does it literally like
gives him a body's by which he can
essentially operate off of and so where
you have all these things popping off in
the in the city of Gotham you've got
Azrael push to the point of like like
mental and physical exhaustion being
thirty years older of course you know
it's gonna take its toll as the years go
on despite although the various
abilities and and the enhancements that
he has what you end up having here is
basically him arriving to his base and
met with like Lady Shiva and one of her
soldiers right and it's kind of cool
here because you end up learning that
Madeleine was the one who turned against
him and ultimately she did so because of
the fact that in her mind he seems to
have lost his way now of course this is
met in kind by the fact that she's like
stabbed she's killed by one of the
soldiers of jean-paul Valley and then in
turn like Batman arrives alongside the
son of Bane and in Lady Shiva and it's
cool because this really kicks off in a
way worse like everybody wants a piece
of this pie right like everybody wants a
piece of everybody loves a piece of
Azrael Bruce Wayne wants a piece of
Azrael because of all the torture he's
endured over the years the son of Bane
wants a piece of him because of the fact
that Azrael killed Bane and then lady
she was there because you know like
Azrael is a dick and so she's like let's
just take this guy out and it's kind of
a funny thing because when all that goes
on like one of the things you learn
about this this new kind of nanite suit
that Batman has is that where he's
essentially like kind of removed from
the situation by the Cardinal of John
Paul Valley you end up learning that
what the suit can do is it can actually
copy the form of others like take on
their their abilities so on and so forth
and that's basically like when he when
he takes on the form of this Cardinal
and it's like hey look like I have
everything that you have now that kind
of allows the sort of adaptation which
is pretty smart like it's pretty cool to
see because what it means is this
version of Batman could like face off
against Superman presumably and then if
he had like green kryptonite which is
essentially the only thing you ever
really need to defeat Superman he could
in turn like take on the Foreman powers
of Superman so like if that seems to be
exactly what would go on like they would
all essentially live in him more or less
as he describes it and so with like all
the venom of Azrael gone the one thing
he needs in order to be able to continue
to function in any real capacity he rips
off the arm of the son of Bane attaches
it to himself and that allows the venom
to flow into his body and then from
there it's right back into business as
usual and so it's it's cool to see this
happen because what you end up getting
is basically like Batman returning and
then like where he and Azrael are sort
of fighting it out against each other
there's a lot of animosity and a lot of
hatred here right I mean Batman having
been tortured like disagreeing with with
Azrael on a fundamental level like
looking at him and say like like you're
everything that I don't stand for it
Azrael is actually ultimately taken out
right like this son of Bane like the Son
of Man isn't
kills him stabs him in the back and
discussion turns into how do we get
Gotham City back to where it was before
and that's when Batman chimes in us as
well I mean you know not so fast
and this is awesome because what he does
is he says like being tortured by Azrael
for 30 years being like brainwashed and
indoctrinated into his ideology for 30
years has really shown me that like yeah
Gotham City like the way that I was
doing things isn't the way things need
to be done if what I was doing was
effective and if what I did worked then
it would have worked right but it didn't
and so what I was doing
didn't work you know and like Azrael
didn't make Gotham City a better place
that criminals were gone all that stuff
was basically sorted out I mean sure it
was like it was more like a religious
dictatorial society but like again like
people must have wanted it because
people didn't do anything to stop it
right I mean I guess maybe they were
scared but like fear is not a reason for
for inaction right I mean you know there
comes a point when you're like enough is
enough right and then you just go out
and do your own thing and so as a result
of that he basically destroys Lady Shiva
he destroys the son of Bane and then
goes forward like he ends up killing
Azrael and it's like like your time is
over like I am here to take over the
like I'm gonna take over the entire city
of Gotham everything is gonna rule under
me and then like basically the city
seems to fall we don't know what happens
next
my thought is we're gonna see all these
different iterations of all these
different characters like have like one
giant crisis event right so you're gonna
see kind of like a sort of final crisis
esque situation right where you saw like
all the versions of Superman that were
across the multiverse facing off against
like whatever that weird monster thing
was at Grant Morrison made on there and
nobody knows where and Morrison's
talking about but like like like facing
up against I think you're gonna see that
but you're gonna see like pretty much
every dark multiverse version of like
every superhero ever ah that's gonna
that's gonna appear in this crisis event
at least I hope so because it's supposed
to be like a big crisis event in 2020
which I'm really hoping happens but this
is a cool story it's it's pretty solid
it's one of the cooler ones but it's
pretty solid
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here too comments explained make
sure you guys have two sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]